-You all know how
to play charades.
Each player gets a turn
giving silent clues
to their teammate. 30 seconds
on the clock per turn.
We'll do four rounds,
then the fifth round
is a charades showdown.
-Ow, ow!
-We got this.
-Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
Gal, why don't you
start us off tonight
since you're our guest.
-You got it. Okay. Phew!
Just so you know, I've never --
I never played this before.
Now I do it? I start?
Okay.
-Yes. okay, yeah.
I don't know how
to answer that.
Now I do it, but yeah.
-How do you do a song?
How do you film? TV?
-Film, TV. Yeah.
-Songs? Songs.
-Yeah, but that's
not the hard part.
That's not the hard part.
-Okay.
-You'll have to have me guess...
-Okay, okay.
-Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no.
-No, no, no, no, no, no.
-Listen, it's going to be okay.
We're going to do great.
-Oh my God. I hate losing.
-Have faith in me right now.
-I hate losing.
-We got you guys.
All right. Go, go, go, go, go.
Pick a number. Pick a number.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-We can do this.
come on, buddy.
-Okay, now I just start?
-Well, you do one.
You can't talk.
-Shh! Okay.
-Don't tell me to shush.
I'm the one guessing.
I have to talk.
-Ready?
-Yes. Sorry, yes.
-Hmm.
-Song.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah, cool.
three words.
-Yeah.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Uh...
-Jimmy
"Birth of a Nation?"
[ Laughter ]
"Baby Got Back?"
Push? "Push It!"
Yes, second word.
Two. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Three words.
Third word, running?
Birth, okay, run.
-Ahh! It was that bad?
I thought...
-No, no, no, no.
What was it. I got it.
-"Born To Run."
-Oh, "Born To Run" of course.
-The song.
I'm so mad.
That was fantastic.
That was my fault.
-[ Laughs ]
-No, that was fantastic.
-That was really good.
-That was fantastic.
Miley, it's your turn.
Oh, I'm so upset.
-All right, here we go.
-I almost want to be
with their team now,
but I'll be with you.
-My turn?
-You're talking out loud
right now. Yes.
[ Crowd shouting numbers ]
-I'm going with my lucky number.
-Your lucky number is three?
-That's three.
-[ Gasps ] Yes! Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Song.
-Mm-hmm.
-Circles?
Round?
-Not middle finger.
-The second word.
-Oh, "Wrapped around my finger?"
Oh, ring.
"Ring Around The Rosy?"
Ring around --
Oh, "Ring Of Fire."
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-No one celebrates
like that, by the way.
What number is it? Eight.
Someone's like, "eleventy!"
Are you kidding me?
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
What?!
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
You ready?
-Yeah.
Film. One word.
Short.
"It."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-What?! Yes!
-Okay, that was psychic.
-Are you kidding me?!
Yo!
-That was psychic.
-That was the best thing
that's ever happened
to me. I mean, come on.
That was the best.
-I think it's because
Jimmy's a clown.
-Oh, yeah right,
a scary clown.
-What do we have?
Okay.
-Are you that cool?
You're that cool, no reaction?
Look. He's holding the camera.
He's about to wind it up.
There you go.
-Okay.
Movie. A movie.
-All right.
-Two words.
[ Laughter ]
-"Jurassic Park?"
Yay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Jurassic park."
-You don't want none.
-"Jurassic park"
"Jurassic park?"
I mean, give me a break.
All right, now,this one,
Miley, me and you.
-What?-
Me and you go together
at the same time, and we give
our teammates clues.
-Okay, all right.
-Whoever gets it first
wins 10,000 points,
and bragging rights.
-And money, dollars.
And really, no dollars.
Yeah, right.
-Jimmy's paying out of pocket
just cause he loves this game.
-I guess we're choosing
number 7.
You didn't want
to ask your buddy?
-I felt good about this one
from the beginning.
-But, then I want something
else, but you did lucky 7.
-I just, I like the number.
-Let's do it, all right?
Me, too. ready?
-[ Gasps ] Okay.
-Okay.
-We have to act it out
together.
-I know. Yeah, hold on.
All right, ready?
You can do this.
you can do this.
-Okay. I got it. All right.
-All right, ready?
-Yeah.
Song.
-Song.
-One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight
"Supercalifragilistic
expialidocious."
Disco. "Disco Night."
Ahh...
-Push?
-Twisted sister.
-The moon, stars.
-Stars, the moon.
-Don't look at her!
Look at me!
[ Laughter ]
-"Push."
"Raise the roof."
-Dance, dance.
"Dancing With The Stars."
-No.
-"Dancing In The Moonlight."
-Dancing in the sky.
-Dancing under the stars.
[ Buzzer ]
Oh!
-Do we tell them?
-"Dancing On The Ceiling!"
-You were so close.
-How did we tie?
we tied!
-We tied.
-We're all winners. Come on!
Come on!
Our thanks to Gal Gadot,
and Miley Cyrus.
-That was great.
-Tariq Trotter right there.